Hip, hip! Rah, rah, rah!
Tiger, tiger, tiger! Siss, siss, siss! Boom, boom, boom! Ah!
Princeton! Princeton! Princeton! (cheers)
[drums]
Mickheila Jasmin:
Can we please start with a round
of applause for the illustrious class of 2010?
[cheers]
Eric Plummer Jr.:
We've been there through football bonfires,
through Presidential inaugurations, through independent work,
Eric Plummer Jr.:
we've been there for each other every step of the way.
And the fact of the matter is that the bond that we share as classmates,
Eric Plummer Jr.:
and as friends, is strong and unique.
Diana Hill:
I think what I've learned most here, is that it's
important to surround yourself with good people.
Imani Perry:
As you exist in the world, you will be actively
creating Princeton, defining what it is to the world, long
Imani Perry:
after you leave, and it will continue to be a part of who
you are perceived to be for years into the future.
Imani Perry:
Claim power in that relationship: the power to name and to define it and you.
[drums]
Debra Bazarsky:
Welcome to our ninth annual Lavender graduation ceremony.
Mariam Rahmani:
I just want to thank the community for
accepting me and letting me voice my own opinions, rather than
Mariam Rahmani:
holding assumptions about what I believe.
Lianne Sullivan-Crowley:
The premise that you will be better
at anything that you do if you approach life and others with
Lianne Sullivan-Crowley:
dignity and respect is an unwaivering truth.
[music]
Patricia Fernandez-Kelly:
Let me advise you to allow your identity to fly,
your notion of who you are expand.
Patricia Fernandez-Kelly:
Let your self-definition embrace unexpected possibilities.
[music, cheers]
[singing]
Karambir Khangoora:
Contemplate and reflect upon knowledge,
so you will become a benefactor to others.
Jeff Bezos:
Will you be a cynic?
Or will you be a builder?
Jeff Bezos:
Will you be clever at the expense of others?
Or will you be kind?
Jeff Bezos:
I will hazard a prediction.
When you are 80 years old and in a quiet moment of
Jeff Bezos:
reflection, narrating, for only yourself, the most personal
version of your life story, the telling that will be most
Jeff Bezos:
compact and meaningful will be the series of choices
you have made.
Jeff Bezos:
In the end, we are our choices.
Build yourself a great story.
[singing, bell ringing]
Aditya Panda:
There are a lot of institutions in America that
can teach you how solve an equation or critically read a
Aditya Panda:
piece of literature, but I truly believe that Princeton
shines in its ability to teach us about something much more
Aditya Panda:
important, the value of community and of friendship.
Charles Gibson:
Above all, I want for all of you to matter.
That doesn't mean people have to know who you are.
Charles Gibson:
We live in the world that is obsessed by fame, and I've
had a little bit of that
Charles Gibson:
-- not according to the New York Times -- but I've
had a little bit of it.
Charles Gibson:
And I can tell you that, in the long run, is not what matters.
It's being a force in your community.
Charles Gibson:
It's being a great teacher or coach.
It's ministering to patients or to a congregation.
Charles Gibson:
It's being a great parent.
It's having a positive effect on others, and it's
Charles Gibson:
standing for something.
[music]
William Russel:
Today, we add to the gown that you already wear, a hood
appropriate to your degree and academic discipline.
William Russel:
At Princeton, these disciplines span the fundamental arts and
sciences, as well as their application to fundamental and
William Russel:
contemporary problems in architecture, finance,
engineering and public policy.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
Whether you've been laying the
groundwork for a life in academia, preparing for a
Shirley M. Tilghman:
career in government, industry or the nonprofit sector, or
enhancing your professional credentials, you have the
Shirley M. Tilghman:
potential to have a decisive impact on the lives of others.
One important characteristic of a well-educated mind is the
Shirley M. Tilghman:
ability to explain what you do and why it matters to others.
[bell ringing, music]
Marguerite Colson:
[Translated from Latin] Eo Ipso, Princetonians, as you go forth, see, conquer and imbibe,
may you be always faithful to the traditions your success is built upon.
Marguerite Colson:
Remember, though, to make them new and to make them you.
[applause]
David Karp:
And, now that we have all successfully run the
great intellectual gauntlet that is the Princeton undergrad
David Karp:
experience, I hope that all of you will continue to seek out
things that challenge you, not just as a lawyer, or a teacher,
David Karp:
or a hockey player, but as a person.
Charles Gibson:
President Tilghman, I have the honor to
present to you for the degree of Doctor of Laws,
Charles Gibson:
honoris causa, Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
She has dedicated her life to vindicating the Constitution's
Charles Gibson:
promise of equality under law, as a distinguished law
professor, a respected Supreme Court litigator and a trail-
Charles Gibson:
blazing advocate for women's rights.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
It takes real self-confidence to confront the
other point of view rather than retreat into the safety and the
Shirley M. Tilghman:
comfort of what is familiar.
To critically explore a different way of thinking, and
Shirley M. Tilghman:
to be open to the possibility that one might actually
change one's mind.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
Those inclinations define the well-educated individual.
Now, that's not say that our goal is to graduate a class
Shirley M. Tilghman:
of like-minded thinkers.
Just the opposite is true, in fact.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
We want you to hold strong and well-considered views on a wide
variety of issues and to be prepared to articulate those
Shirley M. Tilghman:
views in debate and to defend them to critics.
[singing]